hey guys it's Justine and today I wanted
to show you my unboxing desk setup and
some of my favorite gear and lenses that
I use to make my videos that you guys
are always asking about what I use so
I'm so excited to share this with you
but first I wanted to thank IBM for
sponsoring this portion of this video
IBM believes what businesses need to
drive progress is creativity because of
that there therapist on celebrating the
thought leaders who are the driving
force behind unlocking creativity in
business now normally when I think about
creators I tend to think about artists
or content creators like myself or even
musicians but what IBM is doing is
bringing to the Forefront The
Visionaries who are creatively applying
technology and business to drive change
they are calling them the new creators
and this term applies to it leaders
developers experienced designers data
scientists Enterprise designers ctOS and
so many others who are using technology
as a tool to create new world changing
ideas now as a Creator myself I
absolutely loved hearing the stories
from some of these amazing people doing
such incredible things this is so
important because just technology itself
won't bring the systemic change that
businesses and Society needs it needs
actual real people with ideas to create
these better ways of working I loved
learning about one of the IBM new
creators Renata Petrovic who works for a
Brazilian bank verdesco there she is
connecting the bank to external business
and Innovation opportunities through the
Brazilian entrepreneurship ecosystem one
of my favorite things that I learned
that she is doing there is working with
AI to personalize and serve their
customers on a large scale with over 70
million clients their main struggle was
trying to make sure that they are
serving them in efficient capacity so
using AI it's possible to categorize
customer questions make relationships
and return in a very short time to
answer the client's questions for her
she said that technology is a tool and
being able to understand the client's
pain and solve it with evolving
technology is the goal if you want to
learn more about new creators I'll put a
link in the description to check out IBM
on YouTube thank you again to IBM for
sponsoring that portion of this video so
some of you guys may have been on my
Creator Journey since the very beginning
I have been making YouTube videos here
on YouTube since 2006. when I think
about how long that is it actually is
just mind-blowing like my channel is
actually older than some people watching
this video right now and when I think
about that I don't even know how to feel
because I definitely struggled growing
up I never really knew like what my
place was what I liked to do was always
different than what all of my friends
like so the fact that I was into
computers and I loved playing video
games and I just loved all the tech
nerdy things not a lot of people back
then liked that and it didn't really
feel like it was cool but I'm definitely
so glad that I stuck with what I loved
because that love has turned into a
passion for creating and when I first
started making YouTube videos I was
honestly making videos just on my
computer and using the webcam like I was
using nothing else so it's wild to think
where I started and where I am right now
sitting in my very own studio with all
of the gear that I could have ever
dreamed of I'm so happy and so excited
to finally kind of show you this little
setup and this is kind of just our one
simple setup that we have this is kind
of my unboxing desk and this was
actually supposed to be a temporary
setup but since we've set it up and I've
been using it for so long I actually
kind of really dig the simple look it
kind of takes me back to the old days
when I first started making videos and I
had a white background but now we have
some upgraded gear so I wanted to show
you kind of what the studio looks like
and all of the gear that I've been using
and again let's remember this was not
something that I have accomplished
overnight I did not get this gear just
like that this is many many years of
hard work and saving up to be able to
have all the things that I have today so
I'm super excited to show you what our
Unboxing Setup looks like now so to
start my sister and I also have a
podcast that we've kind of been slacking
on but don't worry it'll be back and I'm
so excited about it because we actually
do use the same desk setup for our
podcast we do have a podcast room that
was going to be a podcast room but now
it is Overflow storage so as soon as I
get that cleared out the podcast will
have a home but what I do is I have a
little microphone stand on each side
that I'll pop up here and then we have a
road Caster that's basically sitting
right in front of me that we just pop
right here into the front so that we can
control the audio and and we use the
same camera that is looking at me that
you're looking at me using seeing how
you're you know what I mean this camera
right here and speaking of cameras right
now is kind of a little more of
aggressive shoot because we actually are
using four cameras because I wanted to
show you kind of the behind the scenes
what everything looks like there it is
and for this one we're using the a74 and
this is the 16 to 35 lens I really like
this lens a lot because you can get just
enough Zoom but you can also get some
nice wide angle shots which is super
super fun now this one right here is our
main camera and this is the a7s III with
the 50 millimeter lens on it I used to
use the 24 to 70 but once we swapped to
this 50 millimeter the crispiness just
oh it's beautiful I absolutely love it
and hooked up to that we have a little
XLR hot shoe there and normally we'll
sometimes have a shotgun mic but I use
these Wireless AVX microphones I have
tried to find something better but I
just love them so much I love them so
much I actually just bought another set
of them they have survived so much they
have survived whether they have survived
so many drops so I don't know how
they've managed to to do whatever kind
of magic that they're doing but it's
definitely working for me I just hope
that they upgrade it because it needs to
have USBC it's been driving me crazy
they still have Micro USB so Sennheiser
AVX let's get an upgrade to these
because they're amazing and I want them
to be better so we have a couple other
cameras as well this is also the a7s3
and we usually use the 24 to 70 lens
here gives you kind of a nice little
Zoom if I need to zoom in but there's
also enough focal length that I can
bring things up close so that you're
able to see I recently did just get a
new lens for up here and it is the new
24 to 70 G Master 2 and it is
I think that it might be my most
favorite lens ever like this lens is so
perfect it's basically the same size as
the 16 to 35 can I see that real quick
okay there it is there it is it's about
the same size and I think it actually
might even be lighter like it's a wild
how incredible this lens is so this one
is actually Jake's camera here there you
go and here's my a74 which has that same
24 to 70 G Master lens this is the first
version
this is the second one I mean just look
at the size difference
I cannot say enough great things about
this lens it's perfect so I've been
using the a74 a lot more for doing kind
of like out and about shoots and we use
it a lot for photos mostly right now we
used to use the a7s3 when we go out and
about but those we kind of have left
static so they're now kind of like our
still cameras right here that we just
leave in the studio and do not touch at
all costs do not move the cameras and
then over here is a new little addition
and most of the time when I'm shooting
by myself it's super easy because I can
just hit record on these two cameras
come sit down but when I have help and
Jake is actually over here shooting
Manning our third camera one a two oops
I hit it and a three so this is his fx3
and you've got the Tamron 35 to 150
millimeter lens on which is great for
super close-up shots and you also have
right now the small HD little display
there which is kind of cool because he
can also flip that around so I can see
what he sees look at that it's magic you
know okay and then over here my friends
we've got two atomos ninja monitors I
used to use these a lot more because we
would actually record directly onto
these with solid state drives when I
used to shoot with the A7 S2s because
they had a recording limit so with this
we could record forever so I used to use
those a lot but now I basically just use
them for monitor ring and this is super
helpful when I'm shooting by myself okay
Jake here you go
you go and then the last camera that
I've been super into this is the A1 now
this thing is an absolute Beast like
this shoots 8K and it's also so
incredible for low light photography and
the lens that I have on here is the 12
to 24. this is actually a really
incredible lens I don't really use it
enough because I feel like a lot of
times we usually just stick with that 24
to 70 because when you're run gun on the
go that one is always the best but this
is great for static shots it's also
great for some landscape photography if
you're trying to get a wide view now the
A1 is interesting because it does shoot
AK I don't shoot all of my content in 8k
but I do like shooting sometimes up
close detail shots product shots because
I'm able to shoot them in 8k and I can
obviously down sample it to 4K but you
still get that extra crop factor because
if you guys have watched my videos
before you know I love to do a little
punch in zoom and with 8K you don't
really lose any quality at all the last
lens which this was at actually one that
I used a couple years ago at Sony they
had this event and after I used it I
immediately went home and bought it it's
the 1.8 135 G master I also used to use
this lens a lot to get product shots and
also to do thumbnail photos you know
those shots where I pulled things out
super far and then I'm completely
blurred in the background oh yeah this
lens so good for that look at this
little this little friend this is also
nice because it is a 1.8 I do also like
the lenses that have
The Click aperture another thing that
happens in this little space is I will
do a lot of different conference calls
so I actually will sometimes hook up
this main camera right here to the A10
mini so with this I will just plug this
into my computer and I'll be able to
switch between camera angles which is
kind of cool so I can actually have all
three of these camera angles hooked up
to the atem and I can switch between
those I did a live stream not too long
ago where you guys may have seen I
switched from the front camera to the
top camera and that's what we'd use to
do that next up right next to that is
our road Caster this is the new
roadcaster Pro 2. this just recently
came out and this is what we record our
podcasts on our previous one has
traveled all around the world my sister
and I take this thing everywhere I throw
it in my suitcase it has a little clear
cover on it which makes it super easy to
travel with and then I just pack up the
microphones and you go you don't even
need a computer or anything like this is
it you can record you can do all kinds
of vocal effects with the new version
and you basically have an entire
recording studio in this small little
device it's pretty awesome also when I
do conference calls I have this little
teleprompter here which you can kind of
see it which is cool about this is not
only can I use it for teleprompter to
make sure I'm reading specs correctly
but I can also use this when I put a
tablet on it to do conference calls
because I can flip the video and it will
look like I'm actually looking directly
at the person because they'll be
reflected into that glass mirror so they
will think that I'm looking right at
them which I guess I I am but I'm
looking directly at them through them
through the camera so not only is this
great for a prompter but it's also
really great for that as well and here
we are with all of the lights now behind
me I actually have three lights I have
this little like hair light kind of
top-down light which is the light matte
and I've had this for a really long time
I absolutely love it and there's two Nan
light Pavo tubes that we have back here
and these can actually be changed for
various different colors so sometimes
you'll see me use these all around the
studio in various different scenarios
and we always change the colors usually
to a nice little pink but they're super
fun and super portable and they also
remind me of lightsabers so that makes
me very very happy now in front of me
I've got a bunch of Lights actually we
have this one here which is actually my
friend Tyler's and he's like yeah I'll
come back and get it and he hasn't
gotten it yet this is the godox sl60w
and Tyler if you want it back look it's
here I'm using it but
you know just let me know and then up
here we have the aputure 120d I love
Avatar lights and over here we have
another one this is the amaran 200d I
use this one so often because I half the
time don't even put any type of Dome on
it I just use this and I wheel it around
the office because it has wheels on it
and I just kind of bounce it off of
places that need some light like right
here I'm lighting up the hallway so it's
not too dark over there and then last
but not least this is my latest purchase
that I just got this is the aputure 600D
this thing is so freaking beautiful so
powerful and this one we kind of use in
various different setups and kind of
move it around as we need to it's also
kind of crazy because I I don't want to
say that I built this studio but I was
in here when there was actually nothing
there was just I mean it was being built
so I'm like the first occupant of it I
did have a little bit of say where kind
of outlets and stuff were placed so it's
really fun to kind of see this from the
beginning to where it is now and this is
still I feel like a temporary setup so
at some point I will be redoing it but
I've been so happy with the setup and
it's been working something else that's
also kind of important are a bunch of
c-stands and when I first started I was
not using c-stands at all I was using
like this really flimsy light stands
c-stands are absolutely a game changer I
must say and then we also have another
tripod here which is Jake's this is the
ozen agile 10 which is really great
we've been using this third camera it's
been so fun for unboxings to kind of be
able to get some extra shots that I may
miss on the top down or that it's too
far away over here so you can get those
nice close-up shots anyway all the
cameras that we use here in the studio
this right here is the Sony a74 this is
the a7s3 a7s3 this is the a74 A1 a7s3
and this over here is the fx3 okay now
these check them out these lights are so
great look at that oh we got a nice
green happening look at this oh what
wait why are we not doing this all the
time it looks so good this is so fun
oh my God why it looks so good I'm
freaking out look at this oh my goodness
like I knew they changed colors but we
always left them white back there
because I wanted it to be super crisp
and now that I'm seeing this oh boy we
might have a new color for the next
video so this is the view that I see on
the atomos ninjas it's so good it's so
good I do have a couple other setups as
well but this is the unboxing desk so if
you would like to see some of the other
setups let me know in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching if
you guys have any questions please also
leave some comments and hopefully I can
answer those for you I look forward to
seeing you guys in my next video but if
you haven't checked it out already I
have a bunch more videos right here in
the end screen so go check those out be
sure to subscribe hit the Bell to be
notified when I post new videos and I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]